you're watching the daily climate show
on
sky news on today's programme an extreme
heat wave
grips parts of north america with cities
sweltering
under record-breaking temperatures how
retrofitting could be the key to
decarbonizing
commercial buildings and is the sports
industry playing ball
when it comes to tackling climate change
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions now an extreme heat wave has
hit parts of northwestern united
states and canada breaking all-time
temperature records
the u.s national weather service has
issued excessive heat warnings across
several states
unprepared for such hot weather
conditions
so let's take a look then what's going
on and for weeks now parts of the u.s
have been
experiencing extreme heat with
southwestern states reporting
dangerously hot temperatures well now
another heat wave
has hit north america breaking
temperature records
across the pacific northwest and western
canada
well parts of portland in oregon reached
43.3 degrees celsius on sunday
beating the all-time record of 42.2
degrees which was set just a day earlier
then in seattle
where only one third of households have
air conditioning
temperatures hit 39.4 degrees
celsius at the city's international
airport now that's the first time the
area had recorded
two consecutive days of heat above 37.7
degrees
according to the u.s national weather
service and then in canada the village
of litton in british columbia
reached 46.1 degrees on sunday a new
all-time
high temperature for the country and the
previous record of 45 degrees
was set in 1937. well forecasters say
even hotter temperatures are predicted
for the coming days
so what does this mean for people who
are living there well let's bring in our
u.s correspondent greg milan who's in
palmdale in california
so greg what kind of impact is this
extreme heat having there
well it's having a real impact we're
actually on the southern side of that
that heat dome that high pressure
weather system that is sitting over
the western united states actually
palmdale last week saw its
record june temperature since the 1960s
and that record will be broken again
today so it's a huge swathe of the
western united states that's being
affected and those
numbers you mentioned up in washington
state and in oregon really are
astonishing because those are places
that are generally pretty temperate
that that record you mentioned in in
portland 42 degrees on saturday 44 on
sunday
the average temperature in june in
portland is 22 degrees
so that shows you how bad things are
there uh seattle has never seen
three consecutive days of 100 degrees
fahrenheit so they're seeing remarkable
temperatures
and what the climate scientists are
saying is that of course you can't link
one
weather event to climate change but this
is part of a trend that the north west
is warming
they're seeing increasing numbers of
these hot days and have over the last
few years
and they say we will see more of these
systems as the weather patterns change
and therefore more heat waves in
in more places the impacts are really
direct here in particular they talk
about the night time temperature because
although it's hot in the day
it's not really dropping a great deal at
night and that's they say that adds a
real stress
to the body the heat stress and health
related problems that come from
not really being able to recover from
the heat up in the northwest they're
trying what they can with cooling
centers opening up the libraries for
people to go and
get that air conditioning because as you
say many people simply
don't have it they're having to slow the
trains down because the tracks are
warping
uh in the heat and then there are the
bigger issues there's been an extreme
drought across the west
that is getting worse that brings an
increased fire risk of course they're
seeing fires
acting like they normally would at the
end of a summer
it is a real concern here and while
there's some relief in sight here at
least
that weather system is is moving east so
other places will experience this
they say we should all get used to this
in the future greg thank you
in today's other climate news the
european parliament has approved its new
eu climate law making the target to
reach net zero by 2050 a binding
obligation
the law increases the eu's target for
reduction of greenhouse gas emissions
from 40 percent
to at least 55 percent by 2030.
it also includes a commitment to reach
negative carbon emissions
after 2050. the scottish qualifications
authority has been criticized for
including the positives of climate
change in its geography syllabus
it includes tourism in northern england
being boosted by higher temperatures
as one of the so-called benefits of a
changing climate
the exam body has since released a
statement saying the ability to take a
contrary view
is essential to some careers
scientists are warning that woodland
plants that rely on birds for seed
dispersal
may struggle to adapt to climate change
a study by the university of exeter has
found
plants in the northern hemisphere will
need to migrate to cooler areas further
north
due to a warming climate it suggests
almost 90 percent of plant species
have their seeds dispersed by birds who
take them south
areas that are becoming too warm for
these plants to grow
eco scores will be appearing on some
food and drinks packaging
from this autumn the traffic light
system will rank the environmental
impact of food and drink
and will be trialled by british brands
like markson spencer and sainsbury's
the scheme created by foundation earth
hopes to encourage customers to make
more environmentally friendly choices
and olympia neil aegis has set off on a
world
record-breaking open water swim he aims
to cover 150 kilometers with no stops
and no
sleep swimming all the way from linosa
island just off africa
to malta neil says he wants to draw
attention to
ocean plastic pollution having himself
nearly been killed by a plastic bag
while swimming
at night now there's a lot of focus on
energy efficiency and sustainability
when it comes to new
building projects but constructing
commercial facilities
can be very carbon intensive one way of
reducing energy use and carbon emissions
in existing offices
shops and warehouses is through retrofit
experts say retrofitting needs to be a
big part of the government's new heat
and building strategy
expected to be released in the coming
months so
here's everything you need to know about
the process in 60 seconds
[Music]
so
[Applause]
well joining me now is juliette morgan
head of sustainable development at
british land welcome to you now you've
been involved in retrofitting
a big building on your campus in london
first of all why did you decide to do
that and not just knock it down and
start all over again
um thanks for the question we made a
commitment a number of years ago to
try and drive down our in bodies and
operational carbon
from our developments and one triton
square was a really good candidate for
refurbishment
so it is a really big building it's
about 200 000 feet
on our campus near houston and we
committed to a major refurbishment and
aimed
for abraham outstanding target on this
building
and really we're just reincarnating that
building as a headquarters for a major
media company denso aegis
so that the building's um available for
for good use for the next 30 years
and what we found was in having a
demanding sustainable development brief
for the building
we saved um about 56
in embodied energy which is the
equivalent of 27 000 tons of carbon
we also saved about 43 of operating
energies the energy it takes to run the
building and that's the equivalent of
running
say 1400 homes in london for a year so
it was really good for the planet and
really good for us to have some very
stringent targets
and then um i think you mentioned cost
and um as commercial developers we keep
an eye on that too and
really by refurbishing we saved nearly
60 on
on cost versus what would have happened
if we'd knocked it down and
started again um and some of the really
amazing things about this building were
commitments to innovation so
during the process we saved 35 000 tons
of concrete
and 2 000 tons of steel which was the
equivalent of taking
6 000 lorries off london's roads versus
a new build juliet morgan really
interesting to hear thanks very much
indeed
now wimbledon begins today at the all
england tennis club and it's part of a
packed
summer of sport that will see hundreds
of thousands of fans
traveling to events around the world but
at what cost to the planet
building venues powering events
accommodating and feeding both players
and
fans all these things consume energy and
generate waste
which impacts the environment but now
some of the biggest competitions in the
world
are making changes in a bid to become
sustainable
sporting events well joining me now is
matthew campelli who's founder of the
sustainability report
welcome to you tell us what are the
biggest challenges
for sport when it comes to
sustainability is it the transport of
players and fans
what makes the biggest impact
so a lot of sports are now doing a lot
of things operationally around
sustainability which
which are really good and i think you'll
find that the wimbledon tennis
tournament will have a
net zero commitment and they'll be doing
lots of stuff around renewable energy
and around
biodiversity but the biggest challenges
sport tend to find
is around travel spectator travel uh
even travel of players and
and officials as well and also around
other scope 3
emissions around the value chain and
their suppliers
so you know that kind of the scope three
indirect emissions is what sport is
having a real challenge with addressing
at the moment
and do you feel that sports are becoming
increasingly aware of the impact that
they have on the planet
are things changing so i think there are
two things at play
sport is really feeling that um that is
being impacted by climate change
we see more extreme heat we're seeing
air pollution are affecting athletes
whether they're recreational or whether
they're professional
major storms and major major weather
events and at the same time sport knows
that it has to do stuff around
sustainability not just from a risk
management point of view
but also from a branding point of view
as well sport needs to be seen to be
doing
the right thing environmentally as well
as around social issues as well
so there's really two things driving it
currently and are there some sports
and actually some teams within those
sports that are
doing far better than others
yeah i mean absolutely we've got uh
teams like forest green rovers which i'm
sure many of your viewers would have
heard of the
the the fourth tier english football
league team which is
run by dale vince and doing an awful lot
around you know putting sustainability
at the heart of sport
but we're seeing more kind of mainstream
sports organizations like wimbledon for
example
like the international olympic committee
who are really putting climate targets
at the heart of their operations now
and i think while sport is gradually
moving in this direction
uh it'll be a little while before it's
mainstream across all sports but we're
going in the right
direction matthew campelli thanks very
much indeed
thank you well that's everything from us
for today coming up on the daily climate
show
tomorrow scientists are launching a
fleet of multi-million pound boys
off the coast of plymouth which aim to
collect data on our oceans
that's at the same time tomorrow here on
sky news see you then